big tech has banned Alex Jones and his
website Infowars from virtually all of
their platforms Apple Facebook YouTube
conservatives are split on how to react
I will explain why we should vigorously
defend the conspiratorial frequently
incoherent shirtless vitamin salesman
then a look at all of the other
conservatives being censored how the rot
runs so deep it's even infected the
Bachelorette and the Purple Heart on
this day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
I've got to touch a little bit on Muller
- on Muller and man afford and all that
ridiculous nonsense noise that the
Democrats are playing a lot to get to
today before we get to that oh I get to
thank these guys I get to thank the
greatest sheets I've ever slept on a
bowl and branch come on into my boudoir
everybody come on in let me I'll pull
open the curtain let you talk about the
soft sheets that I am sleeping on
they're so so good getting a great
night's sleep is easier and more
affordable than you think you don't need
an expensive mattress or sleeping pills
you just need to change your sheets
that's why you should check out bowl and
branch I you know they sent me a free
because I don't get any pay from Ben
Shapiro so they sent me a freebie to try
these sheets I immediately bought
another pair another set they are that
good they're so phenomenal I didn't
realize this great sheets can cost like
over a thousand dollars in the store
Boland branch gets them right to you
you're paying essentially wholesale
prices you just a couple hundred bucks
they have thousands of five-star reviews
everyone's talking about it three u.s.
presidents sleep on ball and branch
sheets shipping's free try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund but you won't want to
send them back as they're great you're
probably gonna buy another set to get
started right now my listeners get $50
off your first set of sheets don't say I
never did nothing for you at Boleyn
branch com promo code Michael mi CH AE L
go to Boland branch comm for $50 off
your first set of sheets Bo LL and
branch comm promo code Michael mi CH AE
L you're gonna have to pay full price
for all the other sets that you're
certainly going to buy after but give 50
bucks off your first set they are
absolutely phenomenal to do it it's very
important to do that because we you know
a lot of people spent they spend a third
of their life sleep I spent two thirds
of my life sleeping but a lot of people
spend one third even that is a lot of
time you gotta have good sheets so okay
they band Alex Jones the biggest
corporations on earth decided that the
way that they were gonna disprove the
crazy conspiracy theorist guy was to all
gang up and ban him seemingly
arbitrarily on the same day at exactly
the same time that way to disprove the
conspiracy theories guys really really
good thinking so for those of you who
have been living under a rock or who
don't drive around and listen to the
radio at 3:00 in the morning Alex Jones
I mean he's a little kooky he's a little
kooky I think we can
all agree with that but he's a pretty
entertaining broadcaster I actually
enjoy listening to him sometimes because
he's so up I'll just let you I'll just
let you see it now that we can't see
Alex Jones anymore I'll just Alex take
it away liberty is rising
there see how good it feels here right
now just yet how high I am off being out
here this feels awesome feels fantastic
there's to be a live up my ancestors
running around stuff a lot colder than
this taking animals yeah at home I'm
back to the window with the fires and a
cage yeah I live it so again am i
Beachbody no am i Tarzan no Am I you
know some Olympic swimmer no the point
is I'm a big guy I got big muscles
I've always been strong and I've got
that in between body size what's it
called you've got the three different
body sizes yeah but I'm the middle size
so I can gain muscle really fast you
name it it's hard for me to lose weight
but is just come off of me and soon
there'll be nothing left
again I'm not mr. Beachbody I don't have
all the answers I don't claim mr. sexy
the point is compare this to some photos
will show me five years ago there might
have been a little bit of fake news in
there the in between body and I'm high
on life I don't know I don't know there
may be some things that are of
questionable credibility but he's a
really entertaining performer and you
know he this is his schtick right he
goes out and he's the sensationalist
wacky tabloid conspiracy theorist kind
of guy they decided to shut him down
uniformly Apple podcasts Twitter or no
Twitter I think he's still on Facebook
YouTube they decided to shut this guy
down why a lot of people what they're
talking about is that he spreads fake
news this is the this is the popular
defense of shutting down Alex Jones and
say he spreads fake news about
conspiracy theories and false flags and
vitamins I don't know he's pretty he's
lying and we need to we need to stop all
of the fake news okay I mean I don't
find that to be a very compelling
argument first of all cos you know who's
to say who the judge of truth and news
is maybe when you if you're talking
about aliens and 10-4
have some things that's easy but what
happens when you get down to questions
of domestic politics what happens when
you get down to questions of what
certain policies will do what happens
when you get down to what foreign
governments are doing where there's
conflicting information who's going to
decide what the real news is it's an
Alex Jones is an easy target that's why
they picked him that's why they're
trying to get all of us to say oh that's
fine you can take Alex Jones but you
know when they came for the shirtless
vitamin salesman I was silent and then
they came for me right because they
weren't coming for me that okay that's
the popular understanding of it but
that's actually not why they kicked him
off fake news is not why they kicked him
off explicitly they actually admit this
he was banned not for fake news but for
hate speech five out of six of Jones's
podcasts have been removed by Apple why
what was the explanation that Apple gave
quote Apple does not tolerate hate
speech and I don't know about you but I
don't think that they're turning the
frickin frogs gay I don't think that
qualifies as hate speech I don't know
maybe it's Homo tadpole phobic or
something like that but it's but I don't
think it qualifies Facebook said the
same thing they said quote well much of
the discussion around Infowars has been
related to false news which is a serious
issue and we are working to address it
by demoting links marked wrong by facts
checkers which fact checkers are on all
the left-wing ones shh don't tell by
fact checkers and suggesting additional
content none of the violations that
spurred today's removals were related to
this so at least they're being honest
typically Facebook is very opaque
they're very untransparent but this time
they're actually saying no this was hate
speech this was not fake news so what
was the hate speech they said quote
specifically using dehumanizing language
to describe people who are transgender
Muslims and immigrants so all of the
conservatives all the people who don't
like Alex Jones they're reacting to this
and they're saying well look this guy's
a wacko I don't want to be associated
with him so I'm not going to protest
this it doesn't matter they didn't kick
him off for talking about the frogs that
kicked him off for his comments about
transgenderism Islam and immigration
what does that mean does that mean that
I can't criticize transgenderism anymore
that certainly seems to be the direction
that they're going in
- what if Ben were on that TV show with
Zoe t'rar
this year and referred to so each her as
a man would he be banned would he be
kicked off with our company be shut down
maybe what if we what if someone wants
to criticise the religion of peace
capital R capital P trademarks on over
it what if someone has a legitimate
gripe with the religion of peace
you know Islam says that there are that
they crucified Christ not Islam
explicitly denies the cross of Christ so
if a Christian points this out is that
hate speech is that Islamophobic or
we're gonna lose our Facebook accounts
what about immigration
what about immigration if we don't refer
to illegal aliens as future dreaming
undocumented beautiful dreaming
Americans whatever if we don't use their
stupid euphemisms if we refer to them as
they act as they are with illegal aliens
are we gonna lose our Facebook pages or
you lose our YouTube accounts they are
setting the stage for that that's what
this is all about they're using a wacky
looking guy to so that we allow them to
establish the principle that they can
kick you off of their services for
making criticisms of transgenderism
islam and illegal immigration we're
legal immigration for that matter you
know steven miller apparently reportedly
has a policy that he's pushing now from
the trump administration to limit legal
immigration this is you're not allowed
to speak about this ever that perhaps we
should change our immigration policy and
bring in people who have certain skills
and not other skills from certain places
and not other places you're not allowed
to say this anymore I'm old enough to
remember when firing line had a major
debate bill Buckley's show on whether or
not we should limit legal immigration
this was a totally valid point of view
at one time now I think you'd be tarred
and feathered if you said that in polite
company in so-called polite company on
the coasts or something like that that's
what they're establishing I am by the
way this is why Facebook was so honest
about this Facebook was very honest they
said no no no it make no mistake it's
about transgenderism Islam and in
illegal immigration is about immigrants
make no mistake because then when they
go come after my show or Ben's show or
Drew show or what it when they come
after us for saying something
politically incorrect we said well we're
not talking about the gay frogs they say
that's not what this is about that's not
what this is about at all it clearly is
not and all you need is the Democrat
Senator Chris Murphy to show you this
Chris Murphy senator from Connecticut
for a time my senator I'm sorry to say
he tweeted out quote I know Facebook and
Apple and YouTube have gotten so big
they sometimes seem like the government
but they aren't they are private
companies that shouldn't knowingly
spread lies and hate they took a good
first step today by removing Infowars
did you catch that
they didn't say they did a good thing by
removing info worse they said they took
a good first step I wonder what that
next step is huh looking around my broom
closet here waiting for the walls to
start falling down what's the next step
because hate you might be confused hey
you'd think hate means hate hate doesn't
mean hate hate to the left I mean it in
reality it does but to the left hate
means something with which I disagree
that's what hate is defined as so they
use this all the time they say well yeah
you can have free speech but not hate
speech well what's hate speech is Alex
Jones taking a shirt off hate speech
it's not a very attractive speech but
it's not hate speech is it that's what
they're saying they're establishing this
and they say it's a good first step so
okay but also first of all he says that
they're a private company and I you hear
conservatives say that sometimes there
are private companies we can't tell them
what to say we can't force them to
publish certain people they're private
companies yes
I'm sympathetic to that point of view
however they're trying to play two sides
right now they both want to present
themselves as an open platform a
technology company a simple platform
that just public just allows people to
publish what they want and they're also
behaving like a publisher they're saying
no this will stay up this will go down
this will not exist will delete this
they're acting they're curating their
content like a publisher which are they
because there are different laws
different regulations that apply to each
and they're trying to have their cake
and eat it too and they're not allowed
to are they a publisher or a platform
we'll get back to that and one second
we'll answer that question but first I
got to talk you about the zip recruiter
zip recruiter oh is this one good if
only we had used this a long long time
ago I might not have a job actually but
it's a good thing we didn't like in the
beginning but now it's really really
good zip recruiter is fabulous it's very
hard to find qualified candidates it
takes a long time they're too many
applicants you know you post your you're
a job to a job board and then it just
dissolves into the ether it just goes
away or
gonna be able to find good candidates
this info creator makes us so easy when
you post your job it sends your job to
over 100 of the let web's leading job
boards but it doesn't stop there with
their powerful matching technologies if
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job it
goes out and finds the people this is an
invaluable tool you're gonna get it at
zip recruiter as the applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one's
spotlights the top candidates and you'll
never miss a great match with that the
super cruder is so effective that 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the first day do not waste your
time and money time is money don't waste
your time it takes I've I've been
involved in hiring decisions before it
can take forever
let sip recruiter do the work for you
with results like that it's no wonder
the zip recruiter is the highest rated
hiring site in America and here's the
most important part what you need to do
is try zip recruiter for free at zip
recruiter com slash MKS this is very
important because if you don't use zip
recruit or calm slash MKS then I won't
get credit for it and Ben will have an
excuse to fire me don't let him do that
don't let it happen folks good and then
he's gonna use zip recruiter and get a
new show go to zip recruiter dot-com /m
KS zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire really it's excellent service so
Chris Murphy goes on Chris Murphy says
so he said you know he said this is the
first step okay
next week quote Infowars is the tip of a
giant iceberg of hate and lies that uses
sites like Facebook and YouTube to tear
our nation apart these companies must do
more than take down one website the
survival of our democracy depends on it
tears of rage I thought I was Cory
Booker that wasn't that wasn't Chris
Murphy though but the first part was
Chris Murphy he said the survival of our
democracy depends on it ooh boy this is
how you know when a demagogue is
speaking and right now the left is full
of demagogues every one of them who
spoke at that Netroots conference
demagogue Chris Chris Murphy demagogue
they say they always say two things they
say the survival of our democracy
and they say think of the children those
are the two thing when it when they
that you know you're talking to a
demagogue and you got a question their
motives the the in they'll always say by
the way I don't want this to be confused
with an abortion argument which is
legitimately like think of the children
as you're killing them I'm talking about
this the damata survival of democracy
because the guys talking about the gay
frogs give me a break
this by the way I'd like to point this
out I mentioned this yesterday that the
Democrats are always projecting the left
is always projecting you've got little
white girls shrieking at a black woman
because she won't behave the way they
demand that she behave and they're
saying you're promoting white supremacy
to the black woman because she won't do
what they're telling her to do there
they are the white supremacists they're
the one promoting white supremacy with
these guys here the the iceberg of hate
that's dividing the country who's it
coming from is it coming from the
shirtless vitamin salesman or is it
coming from a United States Senator who
is demanding that we censor the people
who disagree with him when it comes to
attacking the [ __ ] of the media by the
way you always hear Donald Trump is
attacking the media he's gonna repeal
the First Amendment he's taking away
freedom of the press he went one way
what about what about Chris Murphy what
about Chris Murphy is Chris Murphy just
called this website that he doesn't like
the tip of a giant iceberg of hate and
lies that tears our country apart that
is as bad as anything that Donald Trump
has ever said about CNN and by the way
at least Infowars is kind of honest with
with its point of view right I mean
Infowars is a conspiracy website it you
know it doesn't they don't they don't
put on the tie really nice and talked
really seriously he takes his shirt off
there they're pretty honest about where
they're coming from but CNN is utterly
unserious CNN you get frito cuomo
looking in the camera you know all
doe-eyed and like a Mook just you know
that they're not serious about they're
not honest about where they come from
Trump attacks the media sure these
Democrats are attacking the media that
they don't like just the other day Bill
DeBlasio the Bolshevik mayor of New York
City he went on a long rant attacking
Fox News attacking News Corporation
Rupert Murdoch on Fox News he said the
country would be much better off if we
hadn't had Fox News for a quarter of a
century if only you know if only if only
we didn't have Fox News for
of a century did you read about that one
in the newspaper no you probably didn't
because it isn't being reported because
the media projects they just project and
they only cover a trump hate they only
cover what fits their narrative it's all
the news that fits their narrative but
they're doing it just the same now so
Chris Murphy says okay this is the tip
of a giant iceberg of hey we've got to
kick him off of youtube we got to kick
him off of Facebook and kick him all
these things I look I could throw a dart
at a wall I could hit anything to use as
an example of the people who are allowed
to stay on social media who are actual
hate mongers so let's just use Louis
Farrakhan Louis Farrakhan is usually the
easiest one I go to Louis Farrakhan's
Twitter account I just looked at the
first tweet I just I didn't even scroll
I didn't even take the time to scroll
just the first tweet pinned right up
there Louis Farrakhan says quote
thoroughly and completely unmasking the
Satanic Jew and this is in a cog of
Satan full video so you watch the video
this is the sort of thing that you see
in that video the wicked ones and in the
Jewish community that run America run
the government run the world on the
banks only the means of communication
they are my enemies but as sure as I'm
alive my enemies will be made my
footstool and so will yours
the Jews will be made my footstool Louis
Farrakhan Louis Farrakhan allowed to
have his YouTube page nobody has anyone
even threatened his YouTube page and as
there ever even been the question that
Louis Farrakhan is gonna lose his
YouTube page have a Facebook is he gonna
lose his Facebook he's on Twitter I was
just on his Twitter account he has his
own YouTube channel me as a lot of
subscribers he's the head of the Nation
of Islam he's the head of this what you
would call a hate group but the left
wouldn't call it a hate group because to
the left hate is only when you disagree
with the left Louis Farrakhan poses no
problem to the left they want to play
nice with Louis Farrakhan they do they
play nice with Farrakhan they play nice
with a number of his followers a number
of people who were associated with him
so they don't want to rock the boat
because Louis Farrakhan can play nice
with them so he'll so they'll play nice
with Louis Farrakhan who else is on
Twitter I mean who isn't you know they
it's so arbitrary and this is the part
that conservatives really should worry
about because I understand the point of
view the conservative point of view
they're their companies they can do what
they want fine that isn't really our
criticism that isn't the most important
conservative criticism the criticism is
that they're not transparent it's
totally arbitrary they're pretending to
be one thing but actually they're
another thing they're they're pretending
that this is this open space but then
they go in and they pluck out
individuals that they don't like and
they pick out the easiest ones you know
Alex Jones it's really easy to pluck him
out who's going to defend Alex Jones me
I will defend the the wacky shirtless
vitamin salesman from being censured by
the left I'm perfectly willing to I'll
explain in a second why other
conservatives sometimes are not willing
to do that but you know they'll go in it
was Richard Spencer they'll go in and
take the neo-nazi type Richard Spencer
and they'll take away his Twitter check
mark why is he no longer Richard Spencer
but they haven't kicked him off but
they've kicked other people off they
kicked off that other white supremacist
kid James Alice if they kicked him off
they didn't kick off Richard Spencer
what why and why do they let the the
crazy lefties why do they allow that
fringe that hateful fringe why do they
let that exist but they they go after
the rights totally arbitrary and when we
asked for clarification their terms of
use are totally opaque and they're
changing all the time so you never know
who's that you know they'll they'll
pluck out Alex Jones
and then they'll censor my show maybe I
should take my shirt off at least then
I'd have a little fun while they're
censoring my show at least I get my
money's worth you know all right next
time may I only have a few buttons on
this year and so I can't do all of it
it's it's totally arbitrary it's totally
unfair and so the question we have to
ask them because what are the threats
that we're gonna make we're gonna make
our own YouTube as conservatives sounds
kind of ghettoizing doesn't it or are we
going to make our own Facebook or
Twitter or are we gonna try to threaten
them or we gonna with the government
what are we going to do the question we
have to ask is is big tech Facebook
YouTube Twitter are they a platform or
are they a publisher because they're
behaving like both they want to have it
both ways right now according to a new
study
Google consumes 1/3 of our digital time
and our digital minds that's according
to pivotal research 1/3 Facebook use has
declined slightly 10% including
messenger from 4 down from a full hour
per day so it's still a pretty big
number use of whatsapp use of Instagram
have also declined recently Google
holding pretty strong Google owns
YouTube or they are they a publisher or
they a platform if they're a platform
and they're open for speech and they're
just allowing people to use it then they
need to be open and they need to at
least be clear in their rules and they
need to be less arbitrary if they're a
publisher if they're going to start
curating content and they're gonna
shadow band people and promote other
posts and take certain people off and
take away people's check marks and
whatever you know all this mishmash of
craziness if they're gonna curate their
content like a magazine or a newspaper
then they need to be regulated like
publishers one of the reasons that they
haven't been is because they would shut
down basically if they would be
responsible for everything that was
posted on their on their platform and so
all the libel all of the copyright
infringement intellectual property theft
all of that they would be liable for
they'd shut down right away and which is
why they're very insistent on remaining
a tech platform and they always say this
we are a tech platform we're a tech
platform ok good I hope you're a tech
platform they're a wonderful opportunity
they're a great way for conservatives to
get our message out but if you're not
going to behave like a tech platform
then you're not going to get the legal
benefits of being a tech platform this
is all about 2016 it still comes back to
20:16 the left hasn't gotten over it
before recent years the left had a
monopoly on the media on the traditional
media and they could shut out
conservative voices or that could bring
them on for a little bit and if it were
a pre-taped interview they could edit it
to make us look stupid or if it were
well if they were just covering a story
they could distort it they could pervert
that story to fit their narrative they
can't do that with new media they can't
do that with speaking directly to the
American people
Donald Trump's Twitter account is the
great example of this and they've gone
after it it shut down
remember that rogue rogue employee they
said who knows what actually went on
shut down Donald Trump's Twitter account
for 11 or 20 seconds or something like
that
if you can speak directly to the
American people your message will get
out think about how incredibly well
politics has gone for conservatives in
the last two years we have won on
virtually everything the one public
policy area we haven't won on yet is
shrinking the entitlements shrinking the
unfunded entitlements Medicare Medicaid
Social Security so one area that we
haven't really progressed on everywhere
else we've done very very well and we've
done well in the culture among certain
demographics black voters have been in
the news recently president Trump
support among them has almost doubled in
just just a few months this is great
news that's because the conservative
point of view can go at unfiltered to
the audience they want to start
filtering it again that's fine you got
to play by the rules some conservatives
still are refusing to defend Alex Jones
I see why it's the it's the same it's
like the the logical conclusion of now
excuse me I'm not wanting to defend
Donald Trump I'm not comparing Trump and
Jones though they're both quite
entertaining little sensationalist but
it's the same thing which is why do I
have to why do I want to I'm a refined
person I'm a rough I sit my Shepley
glass the right way I drink my tea on
top of a saucer so that I don't leave a
little ring on my table I have a saucer
I'm a I'm a civilized person I'm a
sophisticate don't lump me in with them
I read the Atlantic sometimes come on
man though I don't want to be one of
those crazy people huh right who cares
though who cares what these people think
of you they're trying to silence you
they're trying to shut you up
they're telling everyone you're a racist
and a bigot and a
and all manner of evil they're
slandering you they're labelling you and
they want to gut your reputation they
want to shut you up
why are you so eager for their affection
why are you so eager for their approval
on the left the New York Times the
mainstream media who why who cares
look I get it you're not Alex Jones
you're not the same as Alex Jones that's
fine I'm not either
I'm not concerned about that I'm not
worried about that I don't think well
maybe I am though am I really no I'm not
I'm confident I should be confident too
but we have to defend Alex Jones because
this is the left strap this is the trap
they're setting for conservatives
they're saying mmm
well if we go after I don't know Ben
Shapiro well maybe they'll defend him we
can't do that if we go after Rush
Limbaugh mmm they're gonna defend rush
we can't do that how about National
Review now that won't how about I don't
know Washington free beacon now they'll
come but Infowars there will be enough
conservatives who don't want to even
touch that with a ten-foot pole that we
can start there establish the principle
then we'll go after them don't let them
do it ask yourself do you think that
this conspiracy website should actually
be off the internet but it has to be off
the internet it's gonna destroy our
democracy no of course not nobody thinks
that Alex Jones is going to destroy
democracy
nobody even people who who don't think
that the frogs are turning gay don't
think that Alex Jones is going to
destroy our democracy so then why are
the Democrats so dead set on doing it
why is the left so dead set on doing it
you know someone tweeted at me yesterday
said something to the effect of well
well Michael maybe if everyone on the
Left is telling you not to do something
maybe you shouldn't do it I think I
think you've got that backwards buddy
when the last when everyone on the left
is telling me I'm doing something wrong
I am almost certain I'm doing something
right I'm almost certain as they do that
thing they said it's for your own good
no look I'm just what what do I care I'm
just concerned for you you shouldn't
defend Alex Jones from censorship yeah
I'm a little skeptical they did this to
Kanye West all of his friends when he
came out and endorsed Trump they all
texted and they said we're I'm really
concerned for you man I'm concerned for
you in the end for the
fans and Kanye very maturely responded
he said you're bringing up my fans and
your supposed care for me because you're
trying to emotionally manipulate me I
won't be manipulated you it's not gonna
happen I will not do it that's the trap
that they're setting and we shouldn't
fall for it who cares what they think of
you who cares I I certainly do not
you know they've already banned Tommy
Robinson from Instagram to remember him
he was the British political activist
and journalist who was jailed for 13
months spent 13 months in her sentence
to jail for 13 months because he was
reporting on Muslim child rapists he
just had a video a live stream of the
proceedings outside the courtroom were
Muslim child rapists were being tried
and the the British authorities put him
in jail for it now why because Islam is
a touchy issue in the UK in London but
we can't talk about that we can't talk
about disproportionate rates of certain
crimes among certain immigrant groups
we're not allowed to talk about that so
they they've already banned him from
Instagram why I don't know I don't know
what Tommy was posting to Instagram
probably videos of these sort of
proceedings they've already throttled a
GOP campaign head check this out
Elizabeth hang running in California's
16th congressional district she made an
ad about her parents escape from the
Khmer Rouge communists in the 1970s
that's an important thing especially as
socialism is on the rise in America
here's the ad
in Cambodia
under Pol Pot's Khmer Rouge being young
and single often meant a gruesome life
and likely death they approached my
father and in order to save his life he
said he was about to be married they
asked him to whom he pointed to the
prettiest girl that he saw having never
spoken to her before the soldiers
approached her and she said yes
they got married the very next day 41
years later there's still the happiest
couple I know
that's hate speech it's banned Facebook
would not allow her to run that ad what
now I don't know it sounds nice doesn't
it for those of you who couldn't see
there were some photos of the the
Cambodian Civil War where the communists
killed 300,000 people displaced two
million people and that there you're not
allowed to do that that's hate speech
that's that's inappropriate you're not
you're not allowed to do that Facebook
also deemed Dimond and silk you know
those two black women who are Donald
Trump supporters that they were quote
unsafe to the community and if you saw
them you're walking down an alley at
night and you turn a corner and oh my
gosh it's diamondden silicon Oh run for
your life are you kidding me unsafe to
the community Marsha Blackburn a
Republican candidate for Senate and
sitting congressman Twitter pulled her
ad for being inflammatory here's here's
the reason that they pulled it here's
that part of the ad
I'm 100% pro-life I fought Planned
Parenthood and we stopped the sale of
baby body parts thank God are you
offended are you shocked and horrified
that she says she's pro-life and she's
and she stopped playing parenthood from
selling baby body parts which they were
doing which they admitted to multiple
times on video that we all saw how about
you banned Planned Parenthood for
selling the body parts oh my gosh are
you people kidding me that yeah they
they wouldn't let her run that ad it was
inflammatory no you know what you know
what sin
amatory selling baby body parts that's
inflammatory ban Planned Parenthood for
that but they won't they only go after
the right on these sorts of things
twitter now is going after libertarians
Daniel McAdams the director of the Ron
Paul Institute he's been banned from
Twitter Scott Horton editorial director
of anti-war dot-com he's been banned
anti-war dotnet now is too offensive you
can't be anti-war that you're gonna get
banned cuz that's hate speech if you
don't want to kill people it's hate it's
hate speech if you want to stop killing
people oh my gosh meanwhile the lefties
are trying to change the rules for
themselves so you know we've heard of
the fake news and the fake accounts and
the bots and all that so while they're
talking about how we have to purge all
of those journalists a bunch of
journalists out of Columbia Center a
written letter a request to Mark
Zuckerberg to allowed them to make fake
accounts and use BOTS
I kid you not this just happened they
want them because they say it's easier
to do journalism if you have fake
accounts you're the ones who have been
agitating for us to get rid of all the
fake accounts to get rid of all the bots
but no no it's okay we have a one set of
rules for thee and another set of rules
for me that's what they want there now
by the way trying to control the
internet they're trying to control the
internet there's a policy paper being
circulated among Democrats starting with
Mark Warner that advocates a new
government takeover of the Internet this
is not the same as net neutrality they
want far more regulations now to save
American trust in quote our institutions
democracy Free Press and the markets
there they are again folks saving
America there is that language that's
how you know I want to control your life
so always to save right it's always
another crisis we have to do it they're
trying to take it over so they're their
utter hypocrites on this conservatives
should not be under the impression that
it's somehow hypocritical of us to
criticize Facebook and YouTube for their
for their absurd policies for their
censorious policies for their unfair
untransparent unjust policies where
there's nothing hypocritical about that
and the Democrats in fact the left are
being utterly hypocritical every step of
the way no surprises there we have a lot
more to get to we got to talk about the
Bachelorette you know that's a I gotta
talk about my favorite show so after
Jersey Shore flora banished or the
Bachelorette then that one comes up and
we've got to talk about a little bit
more of the Left attack on freedom Trump
Muller Russia
we have so much to get to and this day
in history because it's purple our day
and I want it I'll talk about my
grandfather so make sure you tune in but
if you're a Hyundai Lee Weyer calm thank
you very much you help us keep the
lights on if you are on Facebook or
YouTube
you're probably long gone but this time
yeah I'm probably long gone by this time
there's no way we're still on well after
this show but if you are go to daily
we're calm it's 10 bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me the Andrew Klavan show the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
a mailbag that's coming up Thursday get
them in and you will get to ask
questions in the conversation which I'm
next up on I believe and then this this
is the one the Chris Murphy save our
democracy Cory Booker tears of Rage
leftist ears tumblr you need it because
you need to save our country tears of
rage lies and hate you get you can fit
you can cram all of that in this leftist
ears tumblr that's a pretty big tumblr
go to daily we're calm we'll be right
back
speaking of tears of rage scripted tears
of rage we've cut the Bachelorette so
the this last episode of The
Bachelorette has created quite a hubbub
also about censoring people on social
media
take it away we saw it all go down on
the season finale
Rebecca Joe kufran my Becca will you
marry me
Wow bro it brings a tear to my eye a
tear of Rage does I've I've never
watched this show that is the most of
the Bachelorette or Bachelor that I've
ever seen I don't ever intend on
watching it but a good news story came
out so we got to talk about it I'm gonna
I'm gonna butcher these names on the
premiere of The Bachelorette last year
Garrett Iroquois yin got the
first-impression Rose from Becca kufran
and this apparently is a big deal
because then at the season finale he
proposed to her and they're gonna go
live happily ever after and isn't that
isn't that lovely but then but then the
huffington post found out that he'd
liked some conservative jokes on
instagram that's right Garrett ego who
got he got hugga liked some conservative
jokes on Instagram and now they're in
turmoil ABC by the way the network that
hosts a Bachelor same network that
canceled Roseanne just reminding you of
that
so they got engaged and he was forced to
apologize what was he forced to
apologize for he liked a variety of
pictures you can see some of them on the
screen you know pictures joking about
how how David Hogg is a crisis actor
that you know that little kid from
Portland the one who keeps yapping about
calling Republican senators terrorists
and stuff by the way the way I know that
he's not a crisis actor is he's a
terrible actor
crisis actors are good actors and he's
awful on screen you know joking about
how Tommy Lauren is really hot the
funniest one kind of a dark humor is
it's a picture of a soldier swinging a
little kid around and then the caption
was what happens when an illegal alien
kid jumps the border and you've got to
throw him back over it's really not
funny at all is what it is that's what I
think it is not funny that's why Garrett
who jihadi had to apologize and so he
apologized his apparent fiancee from
this show is a big Hillary supporter
lefty issue into the women's March and
so she accepted his apology sort of she
said quote the Instagram situation I
don't condone that first of all if you
are asking your wife to condone things
like asking permission do you condone
this there better be a garrote shaped
hole in that wall get out of there buddy
this is not a good situation you were
the first first tip-off was that she
went to the women's March for as the
pink hats till she goes on I know he
stands by his apology he feels so bad
for everyone that he did offend and you
know he didn't mean it I but I just want
to move forward and learn and grow and
continue to educate ourselves okay right
this seems that this seems fine right
but the left can't let it go they can't
let it go if you even intimate that you
are sort of moderately amused by any
sort of conservative humor they have got
to kill you they're so upset right now
it's always and this ramps up by the way
this crisis this urgency we have to shut
down Alex Jones we have to shut down
this guy in The Bachelorette we've got
to do it ramps up the better things are
going for the country that's how it
works if things weren't going great for
the country they could just run on that
they can't run that so if they have to
have gin this up they have to run on
Alex Jones and the Bachelorette
that is what that's that's how you know
that the country is going well that's
how you know the administration is doing
something right it's all about freedom
the left has never been this openly
tyrannical in my lifetime I've had a
short lifetime I haven't been around
very long but I've never seen them
embrace censorship in this way
censorship all over the universities on
the media on television I've never seen
socialist candidates running this openly
the Democrat Party which has been
running away from socialism for a
hundred years now openly embracing it
you've got Bill DeBlasio the comrade
Bolshevik mayor of New York he's griping
about Airbnb uber he's trying to shut
them down constantly all this economic
freedom he's trying to shut down the gig
economy the gig economy which sprung up
largely by the way because of the
terrible economic policies of Barack
Obama because people couldn't get
full-time job so they had these gig jobs
he's trying to shut that down no
economic freedom no side hustle none of
that
and on the universities at Harvard right
now they're banning fraternities and
sororities and sororities are getting
really upset about this because they now
are saying every club has to be co-ed
every club has to have both sexes the
sororities are saying wait what about
our safe space what about I don't want
men in my sorority so now some of them
are just shutting down as a result of
that I
never seen them this tyrannical it's
really about freedom it seems funny it
seems like it's about gay frogs and the
Bachelorette and senators saying stupid
things and sororities and all that these
are all symptoms of this huge problem
which is about freedom you've got a real
choice in these midterm elections and in
2020 a choice not an echo to use Barry
Goldwater's line do you want freedom or
do you want slavery that's what it's
about
that sounds hyperbolic maybe I sound
like I'm Alex Jones but it is that clear
do you want the government to take over
more and more and more of your life do
you want small technocratic bitter
interests to take over your life or do
you want to have some freedom in us and
assume the risk of freedom and take on
the rewards of freedom those are your
choices and and the that's the question
that we're gonna see play out not just
in tech but in politics and the economy
and foreign affairs what do you want you
want freedom or do you want slavery me I
want freedom baby I want to paint my
face like I'm Mel Gibson we've only got
a few minutes left I've got to talk
about Muller and Russia and all that
nonsense and then I do want to talk
about the Purple Heart day because it is
Purple Heart Day by the way if you had
asked me a prediction of which way we're
gonna go or we're gonna go for freedom
or slavery I think we're going for
freedom I think you're seeing it in all
of these public polls even you know but
Bret Easton Ellis the novelist who did
American Psycho he's coming out now he
said he said quote I've never seen
liberals more annoying in my lifetime
and it's not like this is an
arch-conservative guy you saying they
are they're annoying right now they're
really tedious and self-serious and it's
turning people off you're seeing that in
the public polling and I think it's
probably happening even beyond the
public polling so my hope is still for
freedom but you got to stay vigilant and
one of the ways they're they're trying
to get at this administration is this
Russia stuff from the Muller probe the
man of fort investigation wham wham wham
wham what do we know
Manta Ford is on trial now we've seen a
few days of this trial we've seen a very
zealous prosecution and Rick gates Paul
manna for its old aide old employee has
now taken the stand to testify against
him just really not an admirable thing
from an interpersonal perspective you
know you don't wear a wire if you're
clean you don't what you don't you don't
testify against somebody if you're
innocent you do it if you're
and you flip and then you say I'll
cooperate with the prosecution if you
don't throw me in jail or not in jail
for as long so that's what you're seeing
here they're gonna try to make out Rick
Gates as some honest fella no he's a
admitted liar in an admitted crook and
so you've got to take his testimony with
a grain of salt but what are they
getting manna for Don you would expect
after all the build-up they'd get him on
you know going on yacht trips with
Vladimir Putin plotting out the 2016
Trump campaign right that's not what
they're getting they're getting him on
having nice suits
he buys suits that are too expensive
even the judge said you got a guy's you
gotta quit talking about these suits who
cares and they're getting him on they're
getting him on some tax evasion they're
getting him on hiding some money some of
his lobbying work wasn't acknowledged
okay not good I'm not excusing that
that's certainly not a good thing
lobbyists are pretty oily people a lot
of the time that said this is happening
a lot of places it's not like Paul
Manafort was the only one doing this and
this trial wouldn't be happening if not
for the Trump campaign almost certainly
why Bob Muller is involved in this the
Special Counsel investigating Russia why
he's involved in Manafort not paying his
taxes really unclear there's been no no
Russia aspect of this really presented
at this trial it's just a distraction it
seems it's just nonsense you know
they're talking about the Trump Tower
meeting and the alleged Trump Tower
meeting where Don Jr met with some
Russians to get dirt on Hillary Trump
finally tweeted about this he said fake
news reporting a complete fabrication
that I'm concerned about the meeting my
wonderful son Donald had in Trump Tower
this was a meeting to get information on
an opponent totally legal and done all
the time in politics and it went nowhere
I did not know about it that's fine now
they're saying he's admitted to a crime
he's admitted to a crime what the left
doesn't seem to understand is that that
tweet has just baited them it just
baited them into confessing something
themselves because if Donald junior
going to meet with somebody who said
they had dirt on the opponent's campaign
if that's a crime if going to meet with
someone who's a foreign representative
maybe comes from a foreign government if
going to them for dirt is a crime then
Hillary committed the crime because
she's the one who paid for all that
Russian intelligence on the steel
dossier on Don
Trump she's the one who paid for that
she commissioned that the Trump campaign
didn't pay for anything they left the
meeting right but Hillary actually
ordered a commission that paid for it
foreign intelligence from a Christopher
Steele's a British guy and he's getting
in from information out of Russia she
did it if that if that Trump meeting if
that Trump Tower meeting is where
they're gonna lay their hand then it all
goes down to Hillary and we'll see if
any of Hillary's people are called in I
suspect that will not be the case in the
last few minutes here let's talk about
this day in history on this day in
history in 1782 the Purple Heart was
established by George Washington you
know the Purple Heart it's the medal for
people who've been wounded or killed in
battle or who have had bad treatment as
POWs initially it was established just
from merit it was a little Purple Heart
badge and it said merit written across
at George Washington established it and
it was given to just three people in the
Revolutionary War
to Elisha Churchill William Brown and
Daniel Bissell jr. after that it fell
into disuse people didn't really use it
afterward it kind of disappeared it
reappeared a hundred years later over
100 150 years later 130 years later when
General Charles Summerall sent a bill to
Congress to revive the badge of Military
Merit
General MacArthur took up this cause
afterward he was somewhere else accessor
in 1931 to reinstate it for the
bicentennial of Washington's birth and
in 1932 the War Department created the
order of the Purple Heart and that is
what we now know it as the order of the
Purple Heart which has awarded to people
who who were injured in the line of duty
of defending their country my own
grandfather George Knowles won the
Purple Heart for he was awarded the
Purple Heart for his service in the
Vietnam War and so wanted to wish a
special Purple Heart day to him and to
all of the people who have served and
who have been injured who have been
killed who have been mistreated in the
line of work and thanks for defending
our freedom and defending our country
it's a nice they got a nice button on
what all the rest of us can do who who
don't have the guts to go out into the
line of fire and risk our necks for the
country how else we can defend freedom
here in the United States all right
that's it that's my show get your
mailbag questions in on Thursday in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael nul show see
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy Board senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018